1968 humain
oui
1988 l'inventeur de la musique concrète
aux clients ce studio 40 ans de musique
pour le conduire en le musée d'art
moderne
on est ambitieux juste ou fausse que
cette musique pourrait être écoutés dans
un autre ordre dans l'ordre que l'on
veut presque puisque c'est une musique
combinatoire c'est une sorte de course à
travers des à travers d aider d des
chemins différents ça s'appelle gymkhana
donc c'est ferrer que des instruments
avec des plus des aubois des tambours et
laquelle est là la règle qui régit ce
travail puisqu'on peut l'écouter son
amour calandre ma règle c'est la
composition
c'est ce que je veux entendre au moment
où je fabrique le son c'est une règle de
détermination sonore mama règle c'est
l'oreille
c'est une sorte de possibilité de faire
entendre plusieurs sont à la fois qu'ils
se rejoignent qui ont une forme homogène
est ce que la musique vous faites est
pour vous toujours du domaine de la
recherche ou est ce que c'est une
musique accompli si cette question un
sens un accompli c'est beaucoup dire
mais ce n'est pas non plus de la
recherche c'est une musique de pouvoir
personnel je m'exprime avec ma musique
ce comme si je faisais des gestes aussi
je vais écrivait des mots aussi j'étais
acteur je veux dire cette petite musique
de d'expression de volonté notamment des
amitiés rangement tout
ce qui est des plus anciens sa maison
parisienne a cappella maison en 59 cents
et le plus haut sont pour vous c'est
l'orage et le plus vilain sens c'est le
cor de chasse